An edible survival guide, and a hummingbird
feeder... for your face.
Vsauce! Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
Touche is an advanced touch interaction system
that can make anything advanced touchscreen.
The swept-frequency capacitive sensing technique
not only detects a touch event, but recognizes
complex hand and body configurations. Like
the difference between a thumb and a two finger
pinch. Or a grasp and covering your ears.
This could lead to smart phones being controlled
simply by gesturing, or your living room electronics
changing depending on how you sit on the couch.
Or maybe you'd like to talk into your hand
with Glove One. A wearable mobile-communication
device that sacrifices a hand to become a
phone. The prototype is more of an artistic
project than a legitimate innovation, but
I wanted to share it anyway because it reminded
me of inspector gadget.
Shiri is a robot buttox that expresses various
emotions with the movement of artificial muscles.
These include tension, twitch and protrusion, and
the internal base is a urethan skeleton with
the movement controlled by a system dubbed
the "Gluteus Maximus Actuator," which responds
depending on how it's touched.
So yeah.
The Cryoscope is a touch feedback device that
lets you feel the temperature anywhere in
the world. This tactile weather display is
made up of a metal contact surface, a thermoelectric
element, heat sink, and cooling fan. So you
can be in Florida and feel the temperature
in the South Pole. The WiFi and Cryonet are
still currently in development- find the link below.
"Hey, is it cool if I put a sandwich in your
toaster?" "Sure, just use the Toastabag and
you're good to go." "Thanks, just one question:
where did you get a toaster that fits a whole
sandwich?" "...uhhh I gotta go."
SoundWave is a gesture recognition system
using the doppler effect. Basically, it leverages
the speaker and microphone already in things
like laptops by generating an inaudible tone,
and then monitoring the frequency shift when
reflecting moving objects, like your hand.
Fueling free WiFi in the park could be your
dog's poop. As incentive to clean up after
dogs in Mexico City's parks, the Terra Poo
WiFi measures the poop and provides
longer free WiFi depending on the amount of
poop.
Dubai has plans to build an underwater hotel.
Half of the Water Discus hotel will be submerged,
providing guests with a view 10 meters below
the water. And the disc automatically surfaces
in the event of an emergency.
For the first time ever, this is footage of
the world's rarest Gorillas. The Cross River
Gorilla is the most endangered of the African
Apes, with only an estimated 250 or so in
the wild.
Finally, Festo's robotic band can compose
and perform music, and each instrument has
only one string.
I'm gonna leave you with a hand-cranked cocktail
shaking machine and as always - thanks for
watching.